[Music]
what's up Wolfgang today we got some
concept art for Avengers infinity war
which is actually a pleasant surprise
because the art of was actually delayed
until November we were supposed to get
it last month but then they came out and
said hey it's kind of behind we're not
gonna get a ton of them err but one of
the artists Sean Hargreaves has shared
some of his artwork with us thankfully
and as you can see here they're amazing
the detail is amazing the colors are
amazing
everything about them is just they're
really awesome to take a look at most of
these are from Wakanda there's a few of
warming on here that are really awesome
there's a few random ones in here but
most are from Wakanda and I'm sure in
November when the art of comes out we'll
see you know everything like Titan I'm
really excited to see concept art of
everything that happened on Titan and
they didn't give us too much in these
pictures but sometimes concept art can
really reveal how a story was supposed
to go or scenes that got cut out and
again and these pictures not very much
is given I'm gonna touch on a few things
that I've noticed but I'm sure there
will be some things in the art of book
when it comes out I really wanted to do
this video just so you could all see
these pictures I am in no way an expert
on art but I think these are beautiful I
think that detail in these is
spectacular especially the color
detailed the just the effort that was
put into these is amazing to me but
there are just a few of these photos
that I would like to touch on just a bit
and the first are a couple of photos
that show Captain America notice
anything different about Captain America
in these photos as compared to how he
looked in infinity war yep he has his
original suit and his shield is
interesting to look at because he didn't
have either of these throughout the
whole entire movie of Avengers infinity
war I kind of don't like it I like how
he was in Avengers infinity war and I
assumed that he's going to get his
shield back in Avengers 4 I'm assuming
Tony will give it to him and he'll
probably take up his old suit again like
we've
scene in The Avengers 4 leaked photo
that we got earlier this week which is
fine by me because I like how the story
builds up to him taking back the mantle
of Captain America he's really not
Captain America in Avengers infinity war
and then you have a couple of these
pictures where Thanos is wearing his
battle armor which we really didn't see
much of an infinity war just in the
beginning scene and I know a lot of
people were bummed about that because it
looked like we were going to see a lot
of it so this makes you wonder if he was
supposed to be wearing the armor a lot
more than he did they just decided to
cut it for some reason or maybe Sean was
just designing these based off Dana's in
the comics and they didn't really tell
him hey put the battle armor on but he
just did it because he wears it in the
comics I mean it looks crazy awesome he
looks a lot more intimidating to me and
I hope that he puts it on a lot more in
Avengers 4 and then the last one here is
a Thanos and Vermeer but the interesting
thing about this is one he's wearing his
armor and two he has a sword in his hand
it's interesting that he would be
wearing his armor and wielding his sword
on Vermeer because I don't think at any
point in time there was him and Red
Skull fighting in any of the plans but
maybe he just wore it and carried a
sword because he didn't know what he was
getting into and again Thanos with his
armor and his sword was something that
everybody really wanted to see that we
didn't get to see too much but with the
new concept art from Avengers 4 that
shows stano's in the armor wielding the
sword maybe there's hope that we'll see
it a lot more in Avengers 4 so that's it
for these photos again I really just
wanted to get them up there so you could
all see them and I appreciate them
because it doesn't look like we're going
to be getting the rest of them until the
end of November but let me know what you
think of them let me know of any small
details that you may find that you think
may mean any significance to these
photos and let me know if you think
we're gonna see Thanos wear more of his
battle armor and Avengers 4 if you
enjoyed the video hit that thumbs up
button please and be sure to subscribe
to my channel to stay up to date on
Avengers 4 Avengers infinity war all
things Marvel DC and superhero thank you
so much for watching woof woof
[Music]